willkommen zu diesem achtung fahndung
cold case spezial indem wir ungelöste
morde und mysteriöse vermisstenfälle
noch einmal ganz neu aufrollen und
analysieren wie den mord an annika
brille am ersten advent 2011 mitten in
hannover wurde sie getötet ein
unbekannter stach immer wieder mit einem
messer auf sie ein annika die hatte da
gerade am handy mit einer freundin
gesprochen und diese freundin die musste
am telefon alle schreie mit anhören der
täter der ist bis heute auf der flucht
aber es gibt ein phantombild und eine
spur die in richtung rostock führt
annika brill 20 jahre die familie
beschreibt annika als eine junge frau
mit einem großen herzen die sich für
schwächere einsetzt
annika arbeitet ehrenamtlich in einem
altenheim unterstützt ein pflegekind in
afrika die 20 jährige hat einen großen
bekanntenkreis studierte elektro und
informationstechnik an der
fachhochschule hannover
annika ist sehr christlich zusammen mit
ihrer mutter engagiert sie sich in einer
freikirchlichen gemeinde sie hat zwei
geschwister und eine dreijährige tochter
mit ihrem bruder lebt sie in einer
gemeinsamen wohnung mitten in
das haus gehört ihren eltern am 27
november 2011 wird annika brill mit 21
messerstichen vor ihrer haustür ermordet
ihre mutter erinnert sich an den moment
als sie vom tod ihres kindes erfährt da
hörte ich dass mein handy getippt hat
das handy von meinem mann hatte ein
mieter aus unserem haus eine sms
geschickt wir sollten uns mal wählen er
glaubt es wäre irgendwas mit annika
da rief denn der beamte an und sagte
können sich hinsetzen sitte sitzen sie
irgendwo und dann hab ich will und dann
wusste ich eigentlich schon dann hat er
mir gesagt dass es ihm leid tut mir
sagen zu müssen dass meine tochter an
ihren schweren verletzungen gestorben
ist
anwalt matthias waldraff vertritt die
familie des opfers seit über zehn jahren
hat eine enge bindung zur familie und
weiß um den schmerz den der verlust
ihrer tochter in ihnen ausgelöst hat
also wenn wir einen fall offline können
wenn die krippe oder schafft dann ist es
dieser
[Musik]
und ausgerechnet dieser fall ist auch
nach zehn jahren nicht aufgeklärt
auch bild reporterin corinna carroll
ford sucht seit mehr als zehn jahren
eine antwort auf die frage wer ist für
den grausamen mord an annika april
verantwortlich wer hat die studenten
getötet vor ihrer haustür mitten in
hannover
was ist das für ein täter der nicht nur
eine junge frau mit 21 messerstichen
ermordet aber auch noch seine tat
ankündigte
[Musik]
und das macht diesem fall ganz besonders
und man steht wirklich ratlos davor bis
heute
das unfassbare verbrechen annika wurde
betont der täter kündigte den mord an
der jungen frau an und trotzdem konnte
er nicht gefasst werden
wir wissen dass eine junge frau ihr
leben verloren hat die ihre zukunft noch
vor sich hatte die mutter eines
kleinkindes zur tatzeit war
[Musik]
das ist etwas was uns als ermittler
natürlich berührt und belastet weil es
uns gelegen ist solche fälle lückenlos
aufzuklären
am 27 november 2011 einem sonntag
erreicht die bild-redaktion in hannover
die meldung von einem mordfall in der
innenstadt
bild reporterin corinna per sofort und
ihre kollegen berichten noch in dieser
nacht über das grausame verbrechen
freundin hörte annikas todesschreie am
handy
polizei jagt dieses phantom
polizei sucht ihren mörder bei facebook
es war der erste advent ja hat sonntags
diensten sind wir immer ein bisschen
früher fertig und er kam dann die
nachricht
es ist was passiert und da haben wir
natürlich gleich fotografen hingeschickt
und dann wurde auch ganz schnell klar
dass es sich um eine unfassbare bluttat
handelt
die kohle raus straße 13 in hannover mit
es ist sonntag der 27 november 2011 der
erste advent gegen 19 uhr verlässt
annika ihre wohnung macht sich zu fuß
auf den weg zu einem chaos nur wenige
hundert meter von ihrem wohnhaus
entfernt
die 20 jährige will noch schnell eine
packung zigaretten kaufen
[Musik]
als sie den kiosk verlässt ruft annika
eine freundin an
zu hause können
berichtet dieser dass sie sich unwohl
fühle beobachtet verfolgt
kurz vor ihrer haustür wird annika von
hinten angegriffen ihre freundin hört am
handy das grauen die schreie der täter
sticht mehrfach auf ankara trifft
zweimal ihr herz
gestohlen der täter spricht annika laut
zeugen auch nicht an er sticht nur
unvermittelt zu immer wieder
regina h annikas mutter ist zum
zeitpunkt des überfalls gerade in ihrem
ferienhaus in rumänien
eigentlich wollte annika sogar mit
dorthin doch wegen ihres studiums bleibt
sie in hannover
wir haben man alles eingepackt ganz
schnell und sind die ganze nacht
durchgefahren ohne pause und waren
innerhalb von zwölf stunden in hannover
und die polizei war schon vor haustüren
hat unsere koffer hoch getragen hat uns
geholfen und hat uns dann mitgenommen
aus präsidium und uns befragt
annika wird mit 21 messerstichen getötet
mitten in einer belebten wohngegend von
hannover
experten sprechen vom sogenannten über
töten denn schon die erste stiche waren
tödlich eine tat wie im blutrausch
begangen mit viel wut erst später stellt
sich heraus dass annika seit längerem
bedroht wurden
zu beginn der ermittlungen gab es
natürlich zahlreiche ansätze durch die
gesicherten spuren aber auch durch die
zeugen die vernommen worden sind es gab
zeugen die den mutmaßlichen täter bei
der tatausführung beobachtet hatten es
gab auch zeugen die ihn vom tatort
weglaufen sehen
aufgrund der detaillierten
zeugenaussagen können die ermittler der
mordkommission dieses phantombild des
täters erstellen die ermittler sind sich
sicher den täter zu fassen über 500
hinweise gingen bei der polizei ein
doch eine heiße spur ist nicht dabei
bei facebook startet die polizei einen
aufruf es ist das erste mal in der
geschichte der niedersächsischen polizei
das internet nutzer dazu aufgerufen
werden bei den ermittlungen in einem
mordfall zu helfen nach vier tagen war
dann schon eine große suchanzeige die
170000 mal 2011 war das wohl bemerkt
geteilt worden ist und jetzt kam auch
unglaublich viele hinweise diese flut
konnte die soko annika gar nicht
verarbeiten dass man auch sehr schnell
die suche dann über internet eingestellt
hat nach der überprüfung von annikas
kontakten bittet die kripo insgesamt 700
männer um eine dna-probe
420 willigen ein eine speichelprobe
abzugeben
280 männer verweigern sich ist
möglicherweise einer von ihnen der täter
bis heute haben die ermittler darauf
keine antwort
wider erwarten geraten die ermittlungen
ins stocken der täter wird nicht so
schnell gefasst wie ursprünglich gedacht
beamte der polizei durchsuchen darum
noch einmal die gegend rund um den
tatort hoffen auf weitere hinweise und
beweismitteln nicht weit von annikas
wohnung befindet sich ein großes
bahngelände hier links im bild es ist
denkbar dass die tatwaffe ein messer
wahrscheinlich vom täter hier in diesem
bereich weggeworfen wurde hier ist der
möglichen fluchtweg nach der tat vom
ersten advent hier ist eine böschung am
einbahnen damen und es ist denkbar dass
sie die waffe weg geworfen wurde
[Musik]
doch die erneute suche nach der tatwaffe
bleibt auch dieses mal erfolglos
den
kriminalbeamten und beamten ist im fall
ikb kein vorwurf zu machen sie haben
innerhalb
hannovers außerhalb hannovers bundesweit
alle
maßnahmen getroffen
ermittlungsmaßnahmen
realisiert
kurze zeit später erfahren die ermittler
ein halbes jahr vor der tat wurde annika
von einem mann mit dem tode bedroht das
bestätigt ihre mutter in einem tv
interview
annika war das muss so der polizei sagen
ich habe erst gefragt kennst du den wer
ist das denn das wollte ich natürlich
als erstmal wissen und hat sogar nach
den kennst du nicht
gesagt wie ich ihn kenne ich nicht wo
kommt der denn her ich habe dauernd
versucht irgendwie in zusammenhang
herzustellen dass ich das verstehen
konnte weil das für mich so ja ist dass
man schlagfertiger volland war ja und
dann habe ich dann hat sie mir das aber
nicht verraten sie hat erst hat ja ja
kommt aus den neuen bundesländern
und dann habe ich natürlich die drängelt
und dann hat sie mir den ort auch noch
gesagt und dann hab ich dann muss das
unbedingt der polizei sagen als meine
tochter gestorben ist ist ja der schmerz
zurückgeblieben und der tat einfach 24
stunden am tag wie welches chaos sie in
meinem leben angerichtet haben dass es
weit mehr ist als das da nur ein mädchen
weg ist
obwohl mehrere zeugen den täter
beschreiben können verläuft die
öffentlichkeitsfahndung erfolglos ein
fahndungsaufruf der polizei hannover
wird innerhalb von vier tagen über
170000 mal auf facebook geteilt eine
vielzahl von hinweisen gehen ein
hunderte personen die mit annika in
kontakt standen werden überprüft
matthias waldraff hat als anwalt der
familie einblick in die ermittlungsakte
und bis heute ist er sich sicher dass
eine dieser spuren zum täter führt
aufgrund der vielzahl auch von facebook
spuren sozusagen der menschen die mit
annika b in kontakt standen gibt es eine
solche unmenge von einzelnen spuren
ansetzen das natürlich die möglichkeit
besteht dass da irgendwann auch mal was
durchgerutscht ist und dass arbeite ich
gerade akribisch nach dauert und mord
verjährt nicht bei uns und
da sollte sich kein täter sicher fühlen
von annikas mutter erfahren die
ermittler dass die studentin bedroht
wurde ein halbes jahr vor ihrer
ermordung erzählt annika dies ihrer
mutter sogar ein datum nennt der täter
beim gehen hatte annika danckert ach
mama ich muss ja noch was sagen da gibt
es einen mann der will mich umbringen
und das war jetzt auch so ein bisschen
typisch für meine tochter völlig außen
ohne irgendeinen kontext dabei zu haben
solche sachen raus und ich habe sagen
hier wie da will ich jemanden umbringen
ja
der hat gesagt ich komme im november und
dann hole ich dich
mutter hat natürlich intensiv nach
gesetzt wollte dazu weitere sören
einzelheiten höher nur die tochter hat
ihr das immer verweigert hat nichts dazu
gesagt ich habe das dann auch an die
ermittlungsbehörden weitergegeben und
habe dann auch eine ermittlungs anregung
zu der herkunft dieses mannes geben
können die in richtung rostock zielt
ist das der mann der annika brill ein
halbes jahr vor der tat mit der
ermordung gedroht hat hat er die drohung
dann im november 2011 wahrgemacht und
annika mit 21 messerstichen getötet mit
hilfe des phantombilds weitet die
mordkommission ihre ermittlungen nach
mecklenburg vorpommern haus in die
gegend rund um rostock es wurden
kontakte mögliche kontakte annikas nach
rostock und umgebung
überprüft es konnten auch einige
personen in dem bereich ermittelt werden
die annika gekannt haben konnten aber
auch diese überprüfung der dort
ermittelten personen gab keinen hinweis
darauf dass einer von diesen als täter
in betracht kommen könnte das heißt alle
facebook-kontakte von annika in der
gegend von rostock konnten nicht dem
mann auf dem phantombild zugeordnet
werden noch immer stellen sich die
ermittler die frage war der
messerstecher einer ihrer vielen
bekannten oder war annika doch nur ein
zufälliges opfer
[Musik]
ein jahr später zum jahrestag von annika
prinz ermordung wendet sich die polizei
erneut an die öffentlichkeit verteilt
handzettel setzt eine belohnung von 5000
euro aus doch keiner der hinweise
liefert die entscheidende spur die
staatsanwaltschaft stellt die
ermittlungen ein der fall anika buhl
wird von cold case
[Musik]
man glaubt da auch wenn jetzt die so
bearbeitet dass man innerhalb von zwei
drei wochen zumindest den bekanntenkreis
und freundeskreis von annika so
durchleuchtet das man so einem mann
findet aber es war ja nicht so der mord
an ihrer tochter hat annikas mutter
schwer gezeichnet vor allem ist für sie
nur schwer zu ertragen dass sie auf die
eine frage bis heute keine antwort hat
warum musste mein kind sterben deshalb
beschließt sie an einem bundesweit
einmaligen projekt teilzunehmen sie
trifft gefängnis einen verurteilten
mörder
innerlich schlucken muss sich als die
täter natürlich auch ihre geschichte
erzählt haben und der eine täter hatte
seine tat mit einem messer verübt und
als ich das gehört habe habe ich gedacht
wow da habe ich wirklich schwer
schlucken müssen weil ja auch meine
tochter mit einem messer ermordet wurde
und
das ging mir schon ganz schön ich konnte
den ganzen schmerz mal aus mir raus
lassen ich konnte ihnen in den raum
stellen und dann hatte ich plötzlich das
gefühl mein schmerz ist jetzt hier im
hochsicherheitstrakt und der kann jetzt
gar nicht mehr zurück
annikas mutter versprochen
dass ich
bis wir diesen täter haben da auch dran
bleibe und auch die kripo unterstützen
werde und ich habe ein
sicheres gefühl dass am ende der mörder
von annika gefasst werden wird
auch polizei und staatsanwaltschaft
hannover gehen nicht auf
um annika brands mörder zu fassen fragen
sie die bevölkerung
wer erkennt den unbekannten mann auf dem
phantombild aus dem jahr 2011 wieder
und welche person hat nach dem 27
november 2011 ihr aussehen oder ihre
verhaltensweisen geändert
darüber hinaus appellieren polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft an mögliche mitwisser
und zeugen sich zu melden
jeder hinweis auch wenn er nach jahren
noch kommt weil sich plötzlich jemand
durch diese berichterstattung wieder an
den fall erinnert oder sagt da habe ich
doch irgendwie in der erinnerung noch
jemanden der hatte doch mal zu annika
irgendeine beziehung oder hat mal etwas
verlauten lassen alles was so aus der
erinnerung heraus gekämpft wird wäre für
uns wichtig und könnte uns bei unseren
weiteren ermittlungen helfen ob täter
mitwisser oder zeit melden sie sich bei
der polizei
erleichtern sie ihr gewissen denn jedes
neue detaillierte
information kann dazu führen dass aus
dem cold case annika april nach mehr als
zehn jahren ein auf der piazza fallen
[Musik]